the doctor was an absolute [ __ ] last
night you know and not an annual girl
should say anything anything right huh
and he should have been the best day of
the life and it's turning to the worst
one real I feel sorry for the you know
for the young children because it you
know out in your target you know seven
sexual children and the kids concept
it's just absolute you know ridiculous
real in addressing what would have
happened if if you know I said what you
know let's leave slightly early and
because literally you know the noise
came from behind us you know good twenty
seconds if we delayed it my 20 seconds
god knows what would have happened and
what I'm just you know I'm thankful that
you know okay but I feel really sorry
for you know the people I've been
affected by and I you know it's a
horrible thing was just about to leave
the concert she was on a last song
correlogram dear and is about maybe 30
seconds to go the song so I said I said
to my wife she will regard to try and
beat the traffic
so anyway was it was in upper tier and
we we got to the main you know the main
entrance the main reception was going to
buy a pass to our t-shirt for my
daughter but we decided against it due
to the due to the you know the queues
anyway we got to the steps and the main
entrance was only about two steps go and
we are the massive bang behind us and
panic shaking really I just managed to
grab my daughter and we ran across to
the other side of the world but it was
it was very surreal I mean there was
people panicking there was people not
panicking
you know the ones who got further down
to the car and there was do as different
stories coming out you know rumors of
what could it what it could have been
you know I someone said a spirit blown
off someone said she dropped her
microphone and that could have been that
could have been the the noise but again
if you divert the if you've heard the
actual noise any you know it was nothing
like a blown up speaker it was it was
just no you know I didn't know what to
think at the time it was just killed
panic really